in the last few moments boris johnson
the prime minister has tweeted his
response to dame cressida's resignation
he says james cressida has served her
country with great dedication and
distinction over many decades i thank
her for her role protecting the public
and making our streets safer and i heard
you talking there dermot to shiny about
the process for finding a replacement
for dame crested dick something that
will really be in the hands of pretty
patel the home secretary and speaking to
sources at the home office tonight they
say it really is too early to say how
that how long that process is going to
take we referenced before the fact that
jane cressida will stay on for that
handover period so they won't be without
a met police commissioner but i think
now there really is a need to try and
accelerate that process to find a
replacement as soon as possible led as i
say by pretty patel but i think they
feel that it's just too soon to start
setting out that timeline despite the
fact that they were frustrated by the
mets response to as xinyi was saying
there the allegations at charing cross
but before that too daniel morgan the
investigation there and others there had
been some intense criticism for example
of the police's response to political
events of late to parties in downing
street too so i think there's been a
head of steam growing but when it comes
to trying to find a replacement that
work will now start in earnest but as i
say we'll have to bring to you over the
course of the next couple of days a
timeline for doing that but crested dick
will stay on regardless